process or represents a project outcome.
Susan Daniels: prototyping assists in the process so everyone early feedback on, let me start to share the screen with you and we'll get started, for the day the afternoon.
Susan Daniels: wanna share sound and optimize Ray.
Susan Daniels: Welcome everyone to date to the afternoon session, at least in the eastern time zone and during this afternoon we're going to do, part two, a plan and manage schedule.
Susan Daniels: We will get into plan and manage budget and we'll conclude the day with plan and manage quality, let me turn down my other system here.
Susan Daniels: So that's what slip before is this afternoon.
Susan Daniels: We are quite a few videos on this afternoon.
Susan Daniels: To help summarize the concepts, so a lot of my facilitation for some of these sections will be just to TEE up or introduce key concepts and then use the videos to pull the whole concept together for you.
Susan Daniels: There I want to give credit where credit's due these videos are by Barbara walters and she sometimes facilitates these directly and sometimes she serves a mentor ships, but she is the author and presenter in these videos, so I think she's just done an outstanding job with these materials.
Susan Daniels: Okay let's make sure everyone can hear me, you can see me and we've shared the screen.
Susan Daniels: let's start back into where are we what's the plan, and this is the area that we're really going to focus on.
Susan Daniels: This afternoon we've got a few concepts to finish with schedule management like I said today, we weren't going to cover go wide in the topics like we did yesterday we're going deep.
Susan Daniels: One of the things that we do in schedule is, we have to estimate the activities, how much time, are we going to a lot on our schedule for this activity or this word package to be completed well.
Susan Daniels: Activity duration estimating is kind of an art form we did touch on different techniques like three point estimating the simple average and then.
Susan Daniels: We talked about how we would wait, the most likely remember that from yesterday, we have parametric where we go out and benchmark and use metrics from.
Susan Daniels: Historical documentation third party sources that are you know credible an example would be if i'm estimating office square fleet and the cost of that.
Susan Daniels: I may need to go to the local realty organization and get the commercial real estate on square foot cost, and then I can multiply it by that for the square footage I need and voila I now have a parametric it's not exactly the measure i'm going to use but it's close enough it's Perry.
Susan Daniels: We also have analysis, where we go back and we look at.
Susan Daniels: Things that are similar that have happened, either in the past old projects things that have happened in the industry we're looking for similar analogous.
Susan Daniels: That we can parallel there are different kinds of ways of estimating it so one thing that we have in our vocabulary with project management is the estimated activity duration and the elapsed time.
Susan Daniels: Well, the last time is simply meaning the actual time it could it took not so much what we estimated, as opposed to actual elapsed time, and that is all dependent on effort.
Susan Daniels: Let me give you an example let's say that we are going to paint a house and it's estimated to paint inside and outside this House is 100 hours of physical man our effort right.
Susan Daniels: Now we can impact our estimated duration, by how many resources we put on it right so effort is not.
Susan Daniels: How long is going to take, because we have to take into account the resources if I put one man on it is going to take that one man 100 hours, but if I put two guys on it.
Susan Daniels: To take about 50 hours give or take for people 25 hours see where i'm going here, so we have these three concepts, we have the effort.
Susan Daniels: We have the estimated duration and then we'd have what it really took, which was the elapsed time.
Susan Daniels: So when estimating activity durations you really want to take into consideration, this guideline.
Susan Daniels: we've been covering quite a few of these guidelines, and we have many more to go.
Susan Daniels: I don't know if i've told you, yet or not, but I would encourage you to print these out okay and create a little book it's sort of like your desktop reference for project management.
Susan Daniels: When you're starting to doing your project plan in development, you systematically go through the pages and make sure you've done each of these and taken into consideration, each of these bullet points.
Susan Daniels: It is the, it is the closest that i've seen PM I come up with on that checklist Can somebody just give me a guide or a checklist on how to do this.
Susan Daniels: practical, concrete, you know literal checklist of things that I need to do, while this is their first pass and trying to provide that for their association members.
Susan Daniels: We touched on schedule presentation formats on alluded to that there's different types right Gantt milestone okay schedule network diagram.
Susan Daniels: roadmaps task boards combat boards burn down charts right there's a variety of kinds of schedule formats, you need to be familiar with all of these.
Susan Daniels: And you need to when you see that word, you need to have a visual picture of what is talking about now before you flood the chat asking me what is a burn down charts what is, you know.
Susan Daniels: we're going to cover that we're going to show you an example of a burn down chart during the agile day but burn down charts are part of schedule management or.
Susan Daniels: Performance tracking over time in the agile methodology, so our roadmaps that's sort of laying out how their work is going to happen over a much longer time period than just the iteration.
Susan Daniels: which you need to have an idea when it says combat board that we're talking about moving bodies of work through action steps, if you will, that are required to execute that deliverable.
Susan Daniels: I had a question earlier about a milestone chart a milestone chart just list the highest body list all the work at the highest level, so let me give you an example i'm going to pull something down.
Susan Daniels: I know you can't read this the intent is not to read the content on this, this document, I want you to focus more on the right hand side and how is illustrated.
Susan Daniels: The top level here is a milestone schedule, it is summarized it is just saying what major bodies of work needs to be completed by win okay.
Susan Daniels: So I diamond is often this sign used in software for a milestone, so this particular one Okay, this is the beginning of the project and then we're going to have complete component one.
Susan Daniels: Complete component to and the conclusion it's the highest level of any schedule so that's what I want you to associate with milestone highest summary level of a schedule.
Susan Daniels: Now, sometimes leadership if you're a little further deeper into the organization they went to a little more detail about the how this is going to lay out.
Susan Daniels: So you'll see the bands, this is called more of a summary schedule and you can see the whole the word packages Okay, the major bodies of work laid out.
Susan Daniels: This is a Gantt chart view or a detailed view each work package and the activities it takes to produce it, the White bands underneath are listed under the work package.
Susan Daniels: And you see the relationships being demonstrated how this would be the finish to start and finish to start.
Susan Daniels: Okay, and this is a start to start relationship Okay, this is a Gantt chart view don't worry about what the words are I want you to look more at how its laid out.
Susan Daniels: Because what's important is if you're sitting in a meeting and someone tosses across the table some some meeting supporting materials.
Susan Daniels: And they pull up a Gantt chart you need to understand what you're looking at right.
Susan Daniels: One is the schedule to is highly detailed and these bars are showing work laid out over time and the arrows.
Susan Daniels: Are those relationships between the different work packages translation there's handoffs right there's things that are happening some things have on this here doesn't have any dependencies, but these activities do.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: i'm just checking the check to see if something came through so here are your different examples, and this is produced by just these three views are produced.
Susan Daniels: automatically for you, you just get to pick the level of detail, you want it to display you don't create these uniquely one off you build this and then you just pick what level of detail, you want to display.
Susan Daniels: i'm.
Susan Daniels: Okay i'm glad you are with the second one call is kind of summary schedule and I know this is not a task board a task board is much like a can ban board, in fact.
Susan Daniels: i'm in essence can man is a type of task board okay so task board is sort of the broader.
Susan Daniels: And sometimes task force can be i'm not laid out over time, like combat it can just be a list like a big list of sticky notes or just a little a master list of all the work that needs to be done, sometimes it's prioritize sometimes it's not okay.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so I have a question that came through let's see if I can.
Susan Daniels: Can you explain again when you reach each lesson and his topic watch remember for the test.
Susan Daniels: On, ladies and gentlemen, all of the content that is being presented to you is subject for test questions now what I do is we go through the materials i'll.
Susan Daniels: tell you where this is a particularly rich source of questions things that i've seen year over year over year stay in the curriculum okay.
Susan Daniels: I have had students kind of share with me the ways that they've been tested on some content, not the specific question but kind of the type of question that was thrown at them where they.
Susan Daniels: Areas of concentration, are all of the content that you are being presented is applicable to the pmt exam prep exam.
Susan Daniels: This The purpose of this boot camp is to introduce you to these concepts to make you aware of where to focus your attention to enlighten you on things you.
Susan Daniels: thought were on the test can be confirm yes that's what's being targeted and to.
Susan Daniels: identify gaps, where you can go whoa that's a new concept to me that's a new term that's something I wasn't aware of Okay, so the purpose of this boot camp is more.
Susan Daniels: Of a introduction and fly through of all of the topics and contents, so that you can take notes and then go back and go deeper in the areas that you need to.
Susan Daniels: Justice boot camp is not going to be enough you're going to have to do personal study of about 80 to 100 hours worth of study to be ready for the exam the boot camp here is more about a welcome to the whole process and all the content that is being covered.
Susan Daniels: I hope that's helpful and clarifying that there isn't just a little no this know that know this it's be familiar with all Okay, and to the extent i'll tell you how to go deep on some of you really need to know this, I know, pointed out to you as i'm aware.
Susan Daniels: Hope that's helpful.
Susan Daniels: Okay, moving through your chat okay.
Susan Daniels: i'm going to put this back Okay, just so that I can clear my screen and come back.
Susan Daniels: So we've already touched on the Gantt chart right um it will show you now some really sophisticated software, I will tell you what percent this task is completed today.
Susan Daniels: And that takes a whole lot of reporting and that takes people will happen to update on a daily basis what percent they are done on their work right it's a whole lot of them, I will.
Susan Daniels: I dare say micromanaging to do something that will give you in real time on a daily basis, where you are in your project.
Susan Daniels: Now, with That being said, you can back off a little and just before you have to do your reports up line and publish for the.
Susan Daniels: Reporting cycle, you can ask the different accountable parties for each word package, please let me know your status or percent complete.
Susan Daniels: And you may give them access to your tool and they can load it for you.
Susan Daniels: But I wouldn't ask them to do it any more than what your reporting cycle is okay unless you're worried about someplace and then you might put them on a little tighter tighter leash just to know whether they're how they're coming along.
Susan Daniels: We had a whole video on the different network relationships and I just showed you how this looks in a schedule and the Gantt chart.
Susan Daniels: And also having that lets you know where your opportunities are to do schedule compression i'm going to bring this back down again just to drive the point home.
Susan Daniels: Okay So although what i'm showing you doesn't give you colors Okay, sometimes the more sophisticated software will use different colors.
Susan Daniels: If you want to say this color for discretionary this color for mandatory dependencies because when you only have a couple of maybe an afternoon.
Susan Daniels: to figure out how you're going to compress your schedule, you want to add a glance look at your chart and go oh all the lines that aren't read those are mandatory dependencies.
Susan Daniels: Then I can look at all the blue ones and go here's an opportunity, space and here's an opportunity space it just um we're getting that sophisticated now in our technology.
Susan Daniels: But that's how you schedule a network diagram and marking all those dependencies can help you know where to compress.
Susan Daniels: Things that are done sequentially see how this one doesn't start until that one until that one until that one.
Susan Daniels: Well, you might be able to move this one back, which will then pull all the rest of them back with it, so you really can look at a glance.
Susan Daniels: Where do I have opportunity space and it's always where things are being done sequentially that you might be able to do them concurrently more on fast tracking and i'm crashing to come, but I just wanted to show you how that's applicable here let's take this back up.
Susan Daniels: let's see if I got Questions No, no, at this time.
Susan Daniels: Sometimes leadership can get out of control, with colors on some i've seen that it does happen um so don't be that guy right try to try to keep your colors schematics to you know to a minimum, but only when it adds value.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: How do you think i'm Marcus stoppage.
Susan Daniels: How do you mark a stoppage and and why we are at at a standstill um you wouldn't do that necessarily on the schedule that would just you just keep saying we are here, you would put a line in.
Susan Daniels: Basically back to this, we are here, see this dotted line this dotted line always means we are here that's exactly where we are in real time universally across all software platforms that drop down line is basically.
Susan Daniels: today's day right or the last time, the reporting was done so, you would just say we are here and i'm basically then do explanation of why it's not moving forward.
Susan Daniels: Okay, let me see just check in.
Susan Daniels: Okay i've seen legends added to the project schedule charts do you see that is useful always always to.
Susan Daniels: Help your reader whenever you can legends you can't go wrong, adding a legend you're not going to offend anybody adding a legend but you sure can lose somebody kind of clueless if you don't have one So yes, i'm a big fan of adding legends to any chart diagram that I publish.
Susan Daniels: Okay now we're moving into critical path right, and there is a whole video on critical path so.
Susan Daniels: The question i'm going to talk more about how is this tested.
Susan Daniels: In fact, let me show you the video first and then we'll start to talk about questions and how it may appear on your test Okay, so let me swing it over for you and we'll watch it.
Susan Daniels: Come on out there, we go.
Susan Daniels: And we're doing.
Susan Daniels: Critical path.
Susan Daniels: Let me turn up my volume.
As you plan your project schedule you'll.
Susan Daniels: As you plan your project schedule you'll need to estimate the duration of the overall schedule and report this to your sponsor and key stakeholders.
Susan Daniels: So how exactly do you do, that the critical path method is the process you'll follow.
Susan Daniels: And it starts with the forward pass this is an exercise that i'll explain and then you'll have an opportunity to pause the video and try it on your own to see if you can get the right answer.
Susan Daniels: The key in the lower right corner, is there for you to reference so far the only thing we need to know about every activity is the duration.
Susan Daniels: will use days as the unit of measure will work through the activities completing the rest of the information for each of the activities as we go.
Susan Daniels: In this schedule activity, a is the first one in the schedule, it has a 10 day duration and it will end on day 10.
Susan Daniels: Imagine that you've been working on activity, a and it just finished Now you can hand this activity off to the successor activities at any time, including right in the middle of the day.
Susan Daniels: So i'll give you a start by letting you know that activity D activity F and activity Jay can each star on day 10.
Susan Daniels: That is there early start and it's located in the upper left corner, according to the key then you'll add their durations to figure out the earliest that they can finish.
Susan Daniels: For example, activity D starts on day 10 and with the duration of 25 days can finish as early as day 35.
Susan Daniels: that's called the early finish and that's located in the upper right hand corner of the key.
Susan Daniels: Okay let's see if you can complete the top half of the key for each of the activities by completing their early starts and early finishes.
Susan Daniels: By performing a forward pass moving from left to right chronologically through the project, you can pause the video now and resume when you're ready to see the answer.
Susan Daniels: Okay, take a moment to compare your work to this forward pass result.
Susan Daniels: If you didn't get the answer correct don't worry we're going to go through this together, step by step, now we know that activity, a begins on day zero it takes 10 days to complete and it ends on day 10.
Susan Daniels: Now you can hand off to the successor activities D F and che all on day 10 then when you add the durations you can find the early finished date for each activity.
Susan Daniels: Activity D begins on day 10 it takes 25 days to complete edit ends on day 35 activity F begins on day 10 it takes 15 days to complete and it ends on day 25.
Susan Daniels: Activity Jay begins on day 10 it takes 20 days to complete and it ends on day 30 now we'll follow the handoffs to activity g.
Susan Daniels: Activity G depends on both activity D and activity F, to finish before it can start activity G can't finished until both of these activities are finished.
Susan Daniels: Since activity D finishes the latest of the two on day 35 this is when activity G can begin.
Susan Daniels: With a duration of five activity G finishes on day 41 activity G finishes on day 40 both activities R and S can begin on the same day.
Susan Daniels: activity are has a duration of 15 so it finishes on day 55 activity s takes 10 days, so it finishes on day 50 now we have three separate activities.
Susan Daniels: Are s and J all merging into activity X when can activity X start it depends on which of these three activities takes the longest to finish.
Susan Daniels: That would be activity are so the earliest activity X can start his day 55 with the duration of 20 days activity X can finish on day 75.
Susan Daniels: by completing the forward past you've not determined that this project will take 75 days, and you can provide this information to your sponsor and key stakeholders.
Susan Daniels: In the previous example we use the zero method to work, our way through the forward pass, but there is another method called one method.
Susan Daniels: The method you use is based on preference and you may see either example on the exam when using the one method you start on day one, but the only thing that changes is how you count.
Susan Daniels: If you were counting either using zero method or one method you'll still end up finishing activity, a on day 10 with one method we don't do handoffs on the same day, we always hand off the next day.
Susan Daniels: So after finishing activity, a on day 10 activities D F and Jay can all start on day 11 when you add their durations you still end up with the same late finish.
Susan Daniels: If this one method gives you trouble and you consistently end up with one too many, for your late finish, you can just keep counting the same way, you have been and subtract one.
This is the same exact schedule network diagram that we used for our zero method example, but in this case we're using the one method.
notice that the overall project duration doesn't change this is still a 75 day project.
It may take a little time to become more comfortable with the different ways of counting but knowing the difference between one method and zero method will be helpful, since you may run into either method on the exam.
Susan Daniels: OK, so the critical let's let's look at this use the critical path method.
Susan Daniels: Ultimately, knowing how to use the president's diagram and do four passes and backward passes to determine what is the earliest that your project can finish is valuable.
Susan Daniels: One of the things that oh.
Susan Daniels: i'm.
Susan Daniels: i'll dress questions in just a moment okay let's just talk about the value of the critical critical path method.
Susan Daniels: You will be most likely provided a president's diagram Okay, which would have the different activities laid out and some of the relationships, just like you saw on the video, and they will automatically give you what the duration is each one of those activities.
Susan Daniels: Knowing how to add the.
Susan Daniels: duration to the starting day right and then carry that forward to the dependent activity, and if you have several activities that can all start have all come together what I call a convergence two or three things all converge to one in the forward pass you always take the larger number.
Susan Daniels: Well, and you move across until you get it done.
Susan Daniels: I didn't the whole video didn't go on to show how to calculate forward pass and backward pass and identify the the actual critical path through each one of the Act, the president's diagram.
Susan Daniels: But there are resources available to do it in the interest of this boot camp, I only wanted to introduce the concept that knowing how to do four passes and backward passes and knowing how to calculate this is at skill set.
Susan Daniels: That may be required on your test.
Susan Daniels: Not everyone is math.
Susan Daniels: has strong math aptitude will put it that way right some people will choose not to have to answer those questions right they think they've going to take the l right on take the loss.
Susan Daniels: I don't want you to go there Okay, I want you to at least study, to the point that you understand this.
Susan Daniels: Is this you the whole purpose of knowing what the critical path is is is to telling you what sequence of dependent activities are driving that the end date of your project.
Susan Daniels: that's the purpose of the critical path what activities that are dependent on each other, are pushing out your day.
Susan Daniels: Then, if you ever have to crash your schedule or compress your schedule, you want to look what is on the critical path what activities that are dependent on each other, are causing.
Susan Daniels: to drive my project out there can be other work streams in flight, there can be four to 812 other work streams that are happening.
Susan Daniels: But which one is driving the end date of my project what's got the longest the content, what series of dependent activities, with the greatest duration right and zero slack.
Susan Daniels: are causing my earliest finish.
Susan Daniels: A couple of things to know about critical path one.
Susan Daniels: Okay, one.
Susan Daniels: The critical path will always have on the greatest some of duration those activities added together will always have the greatest summon duration.
Susan Daniels: There might be other work streams that have almost the same amount of duration, but it's the one that has the greatest okay.
Susan Daniels: And the second qualifier on the critical path for your notes is that it almost always has zero flow okay what R zero slack okay or zero buffer okay Those are all words that are interchangeable.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: So.
Susan Daniels: When you go to do schedule compression that is the first place, you look is the critical path Okay, how do we determine which X X activities to constitute a critical path activity.
Susan Daniels: It is let's just go back i'll give you something to look at.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: Well, the way this is designed Okay, is that all of these are dependent it's just a total set of sequential right.
Susan Daniels: um and these two come together, so this one can't start okay until this one is done and this one is done, they both come together to begin this one.
Susan Daniels: So what you want to do if you're early in your project you're going to figure out what the summer durations of these three things are and the summer duration of these three things.
Susan Daniels: Well, it looks like this one is longer right, because if this is today.
Susan Daniels: we're already done with this and it's ready to hand off the milestone is it's done right and we're all getting ready to get started down here to hand off, but these guys, they still need more time to get done.
Susan Daniels: So the some i'm durations of these dependent activities is the greatest Okay, so these would be on the critical path so if i'm.
Susan Daniels: monitoring and controlling my project, it is this set of activities versus this set of activities that I am really keeping an eye on.
Susan Daniels: This can have a hiccup have a couple of days and it's still going to be fine it can have the days that it takes this one to get done, but if this particular set of activities are slack are getting behind okay are dragging i'm in trouble.
Susan Daniels: And that's how you would read it okay it's the sum of dependent activities, with the greatest duration okay.
Susan Daniels: i'll float buffer and slack okay Those are all common English words, meaning the same thing you've got a little time to work with okay.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: it's like, how do you do too.
Susan Daniels: Okay i'm green critical path will always have the greatest.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: All right, could you zoom in so we can see where you are pointing with your mouse please um.
Susan Daniels: I will try.
Susan Daniels: That should help.
Susan Daniels: You can see this set of activities goes, all the way out to here or this set of activities is done by this point so it is this set of activities, the top, one that is going to be the critical path.
Susan Daniels: Okay, until we get to here and then there's only one workflow at this point, one stream of activities, so all of these would be on the critical path, but it's the durations the greater here than it is here, I hope, that's helpful.
Susan Daniels: So let's talk about flow total float and free flow.
Susan Daniels: These are three definitions that you're going to need to be familiar with okay and flood is just basically how something can be delayed before it has to it has to begin that there is some opportunity.
Susan Daniels: It means that.
Susan Daniels: Although.
Susan Daniels: How to put this flow is available time basically before you have to delay it start before it actually has an impact down the rest of the on the schedule total float has to do with the float, that is, the slack the buffer the availability of.
Susan Daniels: flow time they can just sort of drift the partner on time, they can drift through time they can float on is for that series independent activities on.
Susan Daniels: What is the total flow there might be a little bit of flow between these activities, when you add them together okay that's your total flow.
Susan Daniels: Free float is for only one activity free float is for productivity and total floated per dependence said independent activities total float is a song, so you have to have multiple activities involved free is just simply for one.
Susan Daniels: Now I do I do want to not move away from this and leave you guys gone wow wow that didn't really go deep I got thousand questions on that.
Susan Daniels: You probably do, and you probably should, but please know that there's only so much time available in this and then you have lots of rich resources available to you to help you understand critical path.
Susan Daniels: There are additional videos that can be shown that you can watch there are YouTube channel explanations of how to do critical path, there is.
Susan Daniels: But I would dedicate in your studies, probably just an entire study period to just critical path right, how do you calculate a forward pass, how do you calculate a backward pass, what does, how do you read.
Susan Daniels: A president's diagram can you pick out the critical path if they tell you what all the durations are right, can you can you pick out the critical path which is most likely i'm the way that PM is testing I won't say is exactly i'm not you know, in a position to say so but.
Susan Daniels: it's common to to hear that they were.
Susan Daniels: In their critical path questions, it was did I know whether it was.
Susan Daniels: The critical path had zero flow that it was the greatest someone durations that I could identify which activities on a president's diagram was the critical path Okay, that is it that level that the testing is going on.
Susan Daniels: it's my impression that it was much more rigorous under the previous exam but here's what i'm hearing in the market is that because they added in all the agile information they had to lighten up on the traditional.
Susan Daniels: methodologies and they figured that because of technology, today, having the ability to kind of auto calculate.
Susan Daniels: Our critical path for us that it's not in is as essential tool as it was 10 or 15 years ago to manually calculate the critical path.
Susan Daniels: But one, you need to know what it is, why is important, what answer it gives you, which is the earliest finish right and what are the hallmarks or characteristics of it.
Susan Daniels: Can you please define the difference between one and zero method.
Susan Daniels: um one just on the zero method just simply says that if you some and it took day 10 then day 10 is what moves to the to the next block or to the next activity.
Susan Daniels: The one method simply says when you start the next activity you add one like it's the next day.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so it's just when you're moving from one activity to the next, from the early finish to the early start box on the next activity either you add one or you don't and that's the fundamental difference is a preference.
Susan Daniels: Could you go over there.
Susan Daniels: i'm float is just the word for i'm kind of the ability to drift and before you have impact on the next project going on in the next project, the next activity.
Susan Daniels: Total float is the sum of all that float another series independent activities and free float is just how much float does this one activity have floaters in general concept free float is specific to an activity total float is the sum of specific activities.
Susan Daniels: and
Susan Daniels: Is for passing backward pass clickable for about traditional and agile or traditional only.
Susan Daniels: it's critical path is not used an agile Okay, so it is for your plan based on your predictive traditional and waterfall projects is where it comes in, no it's not an agile, we use different tools, there we use burn down charts burn up charts in an agile good question, though.
Susan Daniels: Is there a reason to choose one method over this one method or the zero method when calculating it.
Susan Daniels: tends to be almost an organizational preference Okay, and you just need to be aware that what the preferences of the organization you're in and how to adapt right it's it's not a definitive preference you still come to the same answer okay it's just how you want to go about it.
Susan Daniels: Can you should you how do you address expected slow Downs and productivity, such as during holiday weeks are unexpected shutdowns and process changes due to coven like events um.
Susan Daniels: You literally can just put in your schedule on that it's it's like a.
Susan Daniels: an activity that every every work stream has just sort of a block that you would put in just call it holidays right and so each work stream would have a holiday.
Susan Daniels: Activity associated with it, and it would all line up for the same dates during the holidays.
Susan Daniels: And it would just kind of say that you know we're we're working really fast and then there everybody just kind of had the holidays and then we picked back up and went like this.
Susan Daniels: or it could be shut down or things like that, but every work stream would have that same activity assigned to it, so it would just consistently show throughout the schedule, I hope, that's helpful.
Susan Daniels: um please explain this i've been asked to explain late start and i'm like finished calculation that's a backward pass and i'm going to ask you, in the interest of time to go.
Susan Daniels: If you really want to understand how to do this manually then go watch some YouTube videos on it, or some of the Pacific to.
Susan Daniels: Our other platt learning platforms, that you have access to videos on on calculating critical path, again, I think that that we're really focused more on was the characteristics of it, why would you want to know how to identify it can, can you identify it.
Susan Daniels: Could agile use Gantt traditional method as well, it typically does not i'm not saying it can maybe in a hybrid environment where you've got different kinds of methodologies being executed on your project.
Susan Daniels: We got business kind of working off of Ghana traditional and you've got on your it folks working in agile, you might be able to.
Susan Daniels: hang on I just got something come through.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: Okay nevermind something came through the chat um.
Susan Daniels: So I just want you to know that.
Susan Daniels: We have different tools that we use to manage work over time.
Susan Daniels: Traditional usually we use the Gantt chart because it just lays it all out Nice and neatly in the Gantt chart is what I showed you that's what I drugged down on the screen in agile, we we use um.
Susan Daniels: Let me, let me just pause for a moment.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so.
Susan Daniels: In agile, we have iterations right and we on this self empowered team It estimates the work itself it decides what's an achievable amount of work to happen within this this time box.
Susan Daniels: And the way that it's verified the progress is actually verified, is that you have a sprint review, and this is when they DEMO what they've built to get feedback so they're able to confirm progress, based upon this sprint review at the end of each.
Susan Daniels: iteration or each sprint.
Susan Daniels: But the work may need additional enhancements or fixes or repairs or bugs may need to be addressed some of that work may go back into the work backlog then have to come back through again but they only get.
Susan Daniels: Credit for work that is completed, even if there is an opportunity to make it better that's considered a new user story and goes back into the backlog.
Susan Daniels: Susan.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so.
Susan Daniels: I got a good question here, so the question is about how do you put in holidays or you know blackouts or things that are going to basically be work slowdowns or work stoppages um.
Susan Daniels: And I got a response Susan concerning James question i'm assuming that information can be pre determined in the schedule.
Susan Daniels: Much like accounting for employees pto scheduled outages for the overall project.
Susan Daniels: um yeah, the only thing you can put on the schedule is something that you're already aware of right, but if you just want to kind of mark on your schedule that this is going to just be a really slow period okay.
Susan Daniels: You could add if you wanted to have one happen, you could just add to each whenever it occurs just had holiday right and holiday would occur during this period for, and we could just say this is a holiday and each one of them would have.
Susan Daniels: an activity that would say this is this is now in the holiday period, and this would then pick up after the holiday period I, this will be this one says.
Susan Daniels: i'm going to be on holiday from here to here, and this is probably going to move out to here because you're recognizing the holiday going on, you would just load it where it is applicable in your schedule.
Susan Daniels: But yeah you can load anything you don't know for sure okay.
Susan Daniels: Is is concept of critical path appropriate to agile methodology F at all, not not necessarily know we use a lot of different other a lot of different other sorry about that.
Susan Daniels: We use different techniques to prioritize the work organize the work and lay it out over time and story right now the roadmap that we're going to use the implementation roadmap is an example versus the Gantt chart.
Susan Daniels: Is it coming to practice to add a time buffer to the critical path has other paths have inherent buffer on if you actually add buffer.
Susan Daniels: You now moving from critical path to critical chain critical path has zero float there when one thing is the next thing begins, there is no slack there is no float.
Susan Daniels: We just got to get it done it's driving the schedule okay so by virtue of the fact you're talking about adding buffer you're literally no longer talking about the critical path, but.
Susan Daniels: Once you identify what your critical path is in first draft second draft of the schedule, then you may want to add a like an activity near the end the final.
Susan Daniels: block, if you will, and you can call that the critical chain, the last the last chain in the whole.
Susan Daniels: event this critical chain method just says we're going to manage float for the whole project out of this one activity or up a day we're down a day we're down two days out of our 10 day buffer.
Susan Daniels: Okay, maybe I gained a day back, but then I lose a week Oh, my goodness Mike I only have three days left, right now, something good happens I recover a day you constantly just report on your critical chain.
Susan Daniels: That last activity, how much buffer do you have left but that's not what we're covering we're covering critical chain, the critical.
Susan Daniels: we're not covering critical chain on the test necessarily recovering critical path.
Susan Daniels: So you can't add buffer okay you can't add buffer to your critical chain, because it's supposed to have zero flow right, but if you do decide to add one at the very end you're now talking about critical change.
Susan Daniels: The slide says on do not.
Susan Daniels: Okay, how do you factor in on you don't factor, and when you're done identifying your critical chain you don't factor in that somebody actually i'm.
Susan Daniels: going to.
Susan Daniels: Whether they're available or not you've already put that into your estimated durations of how long that activity is going to cost or it's going to take.
Susan Daniels: That should be in your duration, if you know she's going to be out for a week and then she's going to need.
Susan Daniels: she's going to start before she goes swimming gone for a week and then she comes back and finishes it that duration should incorporate any pto that's taken okay it's in the duration so that's why you can assume zero float between the activities.
Susan Daniels: Oh, are you saying that mean doing the act that critical chain that last one, and then is called patting yes, Sir, yes ma'am That is exactly what it is, but it's obvious is because he was it's reported and it's shared.
Susan Daniels: And everyone buys into what that last chain amount is going to be you get an acceptable amount and then you're managing your project reporting just a bomb on how much you've got left overall.
Susan Daniels: Okay um I need to move on, for sure there is resource smoothing and leveling okay so we're trying to optimize our schedule right we're trying to figure out how to get this done the most efficient, effective way, and we know what series independent activities are driving our.
Susan Daniels: Our early finish well when we do our first pass of our.
Susan Daniels: of our schedule, sometimes we get informed.
Susan Daniels: Sorry, sometimes we get feedback okay that we've over allocated work to someone or that.
Susan Daniels: They can't work that many hours of the day, or the another project manager has booked them and then you book them for the same day.
Susan Daniels: And they like a super Sally says haha no guys you figure it out, but I can't do all that in this time period so, then you have to go back and rework your schedule.
Susan Daniels: And we have two methodologies, that we can use resource smoothing and resource leveling so give me a moment and I will TEE up a.
Susan Daniels: couple of.
Susan Daniels: videos for you, they talk about that.
Susan Daniels: resource leveling.
When we develop our project schedule, we perform a forward pass in a backward pass to determine where we have flexibility in our schedule.
The primary goal is to protect the activities on the critical path.
Identifying free flow in non critical path activities helps us to identify the activities which can lend flexibility in order to meet the critical path deadlines.
If our critical path activities are running late and our deadline is at risk, we will rely on those activities with free float.
Consider activity ah, we can determine that there are five months of free float before the next activity activity, he must begin.
That is a lot of flexibility now let's say that we lose two full time resources from activity seed due to unexpected turnover.
Now the critical path is in danger, and without intervention our project will be delayed let's evaluate our non critical activities to determine if a solution exists.
Luckily activity, he requires the same skill set as activity see activity, he currently has four full time resources, who will take two months to complete the activity.
take a moment to evaluate this situation and try to think of a solution, you may pause the video at any time to determine the answer and then resume the video when you're ready to hear the correct answer.
Susan Daniels: What if we take two full time resources from activity age and shift them to activity see if this was your solution good thinking this is called resource leveling.
Susan Daniels: Obviously, we have to make some assumptions about the skill sets and abilities of the resources if they aren't identical we might adjust the number of resources that we shift accordingly.
Susan Daniels: Once we begin to level resources taking them from a non critical activity and moving them to the critical activity.
Susan Daniels: What will the result be what will happen to activity ah, if we remove two of the four resources or cut the staffing for that activity and half feel free to pause the video at any time and resume when you're ready.
If you said that activity, he will double in duration, because half of the resources have been lost you're correct parametric estimating allows us to estimate and adjust durations based on the number of assigned resources.
Now activity, he will take four months instead of two, but there is no harm done in fact there are still three months of free float available on this activity.
And because you were able to shift to resources to activity, see to replace the two last resources, the critical path has been protected and the overall project schedule can be met, this is an example of resource leveling.
resource leveling is a way to balance resource availability, with the demands of various activities, the resources could be people equipment or materials let's consider another scenario.
During planning we missed the fact that the same equipment is needed by activity H and activity J, at the same time, the equipment can only be used by one activity at a time.
We can either decide that the activities must share the equipment each using it 50% of the time, or we can fully dedicated to one of the activities, removing its availability completely from the other activity.
Either way, this is another example of resource leveling which will result in the lengthening of any activity that loses resources.
Susan Daniels: A more extreme example of resource leveling is when resources are lost from an activity and cannot be replaced by another activity.
Susan Daniels: If this happens on a non critical path the available float will help to buffer the loss of resources, but what if the resources are lost from an activity on the critical path.
Susan Daniels: The duration of the activity will increase and your project schedule will be in jeopardy.
Susan Daniels: You will work with your sponsor and stakeholders to determine which constraints are most important scope cost or time, this will help you to take the most appropriate action for the success of the project.
If you would like to consider resource leveling on your project consider doing it by hand.
Although project management scheduling software can be very sophisticated it can't replace the intricate knowledge of the project team.
resource leveling is a delicate process that moves resources from one task to another.
Ultimately, those resources are people with unique skill sets experience and personalities as a project manager, you may know, these unique characteristics that your software can't possibly know.
hiring decisions are made by people and reassignment should also have the human touch this expert judgment will help with the continued success of your project.
Susan Daniels: As a project manager schedule planning is a critical exercise you plan for the deal situation and you also plan for contingencies.
Susan Daniels: The primary goal is to protect the activities on the critical path generally there is some flexibility in your schedule and you determine where it is by performing the forward and backward passes through your schedule.
Susan Daniels: The free flow in non critical path activities is there to lend flexibility in order to meet the critical path deadlines, but sometimes we may encounter conflicts that are not along the critical path where free float can still come in handy.
Susan Daniels: Although we take a lot of time to carefully plan our schedule, sometimes we make mistakes and we don't realize it until project work has begun.
Susan Daniels: Perhaps we have assigned the same resource to two activities that are supposed to be happening at the same time.
Susan Daniels: These can be human resources, or they can be machines or tools that are limited in availability.
Susan Daniels: Consider activities H and J, unfortunately, we have accidentally assign the same individual to both of these activities will call her Louise.
Susan Daniels: Louise has specialized knowledge and experience, and we consider her to be irreplaceable leveling our resources by bringing someone in from another activity to replace Louise is not an option.
Susan Daniels: And we don't want to risk burnout or errors by having Louise work overtime, we will have to consider a different resource optimization technique.
Susan Daniels: Can you think of one and how we might apply it, you may pause the video at any time to determine the answer and then resume the video when you're ready to hear the correct answer.
Susan Daniels: If you said resource smoothing that is correct, there are two resource optimization techniques leveling and smoothing.
Susan Daniels: we've already determined that resource leveling is not an option, since Louise is not replaceable, so we will use resource smoothing instead.
Susan Daniels: resource smoothing does not change the number of resources or the duration of an activity, it simply uses float to delay the activity to a start date that resolves a resource issue.
Susan Daniels: Louise is assigned to activities H and J activity, he has five months of float well activity Jay has two months of float one of these activities as a better choice than the other when it comes to resource smoothing do you know which one you can pause now and resume when you're ready.
Susan Daniels: If you said that activity H is the better one, to use for resource smoothing that is correct, using the available float we can delay activity age by four months so that it starts in August, rather than April.
Susan Daniels: This resolves the resource conflict with Louise So why did we choose activity, he instead of delaying activity Jay.
Susan Daniels: Even after delaying activity ah by four months, there is still one month of remaining float on path one, this is very important for controlling the schedule.
Susan Daniels: If we had decided to delay activity J instead we would have used all of the available float on path to and as a result, we would have made it a critical activity with no more available float.
Susan Daniels: That creates unnecessary risks to our schedule, so we probably wouldn't use resource moving with activity J in this situation.
resource smoothing uses the available flow to delay an activity to start at a later point in time.
The activity doesn't change in duration and the resource assignments don't change either the activity still cost the same as well.
You may need to consider any impact to your budget since the timing of the activity will be changing, and that will have an effect on when you will have expenditures for this activity.
You using resource smoothing helps to resolve any resource conflicts, you may encounter in the example with Louise we used to human resource conflict.
resource smoothing can also be used to resolve conflicts with other types of resources, such as equipment.
let's say that you need to do two types of tests on your network one is volume testing to make sure customers can access your website, even during high traffic times.
The other is data security testing to make sure your website is safe from hackers in order for these two tests to be performed independently, you will need to schedule these activities at different times.
If you miss this during your schedule planning, you may need to rely on resource smoothing to correct any resource conflicts before these tests can be conducted.
You may consider using project management software to assist with resource smoothing However it can't replace the intricate knowledge of the project team.
As a project manager, you may know, these unique properties of your project activities that your software can't possibly know using expert judgment will help with the continued success of your project.
Susan Daniels: Okay it's that time for a break i'm going to go ahead and encourage you guys to get up move around and use this break time it'll be a.
Susan Daniels: 15 minute break use it to volunteer to start a study group to connect with people in your general area or your business.
Susan Daniels: domain or within your group that is sponsoring you this is a great time for peer to peer conversations.
Susan Daniels: When we get back we're going to talk about scheduled compression techniques which will have to do with fast tracking and crashing and we'll get launched into our budget management segment Have a nice break.